a bombshell breakthrough for one of
America's most notorious unsolved serial
killer cases police arresting Rex
heuerman last night for the Gilgo Beach
serial killings the grizzly set of
murders of almost a dozen women that's
haunted law enforcement for over a
decade back in 2010 and 2011 New York
authorities discovered 11 sets of human
remains strewn along a Suburban Long
Island beach Highway
hewerman has been arrested in connection
with the first four murders their bodies
were all found in burlap sacks along the
beach in December 2010. another six
women and a toddler were found in the
following months and police will see if
huerman had any connection to those
killings today he pleaded not guilty to
six murder counts officials say they
won't stop until they solve all the
killings
Rex Herriman is a demon
that walks Among Us
a predator
that ruined families
and if not for the members of this task
force
he would still be on the streets today
however even with this arrest
we're not done
cops linking him to murders through DNA
left on a discarded pizza box the
accused killer Was An Architect married
with a daughter and a stepson and his
neighbors are stunned
the guy's been quiet never really
bothers anybody
um you were kind of shocked it's crazy
it's mind-blowing it's you know quiet
Massapequa Park I've had Small Talk uh
with the gentleman
um because he would do like woodwork
just you know
average guy living in you know Suburban
neighborhood
so this case was called for a very long
time how did detectives put it together
ultimately it was resurrected a couple
years ago by a task force that had been
reinstated there on Long Island in
Suffolk County and they linked together
some circles circumstantial evidence
that included a green truck that he
drove that was registered to his brother
um and they finally linked it via DNA
evidence good old DNA evidence that
seems to be resurrecting and identifying
a lot of these perps from these
seemingly cold cases I talked to Paul
Morrow today earlier on my fox True
Crime podcast he was an NYPD detective
and he worked in the intelligence as an
augment to the task force back in 2010
when they were first searching for
Shannon Gilbert's body and he pointed
out that back then the purpose to call
the families and taunt them and it was
always the same time of day the same day
of the week from a pay phone or phone
around Midtown so back then authorities
were trying to ask her train trying to
triangulate where these calls were
coming from and at the end of the day
advancement in DNA genealogical forensic
evidence has brought us to this point
like we saw in Green River and Spokane
serial killer I want to point out one
important thing here that while today is
absolutely cause for appreciation for
law enforcement celebration this is one
step in the road to actual Victory and
closure this is an arrest and
identification not a conviction yet and
we don't know about all those other
bodies that were discovered with
different types of manners of death and
the different types of victims and most
can change we saw that with a Spokane
serial killer right people argue no no
this body can't be him he always used a
gunshot this was no plastic bag ammos
develop as serial killers learn and
develop what gratifies them what things
they can get away with what manners are
more efficient so here it might be one
person and he evolved in the Mariner of
his gruesome killings or there might be
many so I just put out there I know law
enforcement Works tirelessly to
ascertain who is responsible for all
those bodies and I know that we can
count on the community support as well
for appreciation in this moment and for
continued support to identify the any
additional murderers behind all the
discoveries of all of those bodies and
yet another reason not to defund the
police because it goes toward detective
work too and cold case research it is
not all about beat street that the left
loves to hammer what did you make of the
neighbors just shocked that they've been
living next to an accused serial killer
for over a decade
it shows and I would agree with Emily's
last Point around
um this is the first step and hopefully
this is the first step a domino dominoes
will keep falling here I listen to well
to your point he looks like someone that
could be your neighbor at work he could
be your neighbor in your and were you in
the community you live he could be your
neighbor in the community where you may
you know take your kids to the Boys and
Girls Club wherever it may be so this is
um it's frightening and startling in
that regard I have to tell you the
watching all those police officers
Federal uh state and local officials
there in that press conference
um is is painful as some you know we it
was a long press conference it had to be
painful for the families I was so moved
when all of them offered their
condolences to the families the
surviving family members uh and I was
moved as all of them talked about the
cooperation that they all had in this in
this lengthy investigation police
officers and those in law enforcement
never gave up here uh and their
faithfulness and their thoroughness is
to this case should should if there are
others out there Emily that participated
that that someone else that that was
involved in this they should know that
this task force uh in this community uh
that our resolve uh will will not be
exhausted here uh and then we will find
them if indeed he's not the only one
Emily mentioned the guy was making calls
to the victims families yeah from work
yeah how sadistic do you have to be to
do that how sadistic do you have to be
to Google child pornography to Google
torture porn as he did often on his
computer 200 searches for these Gilgo
murders in just four months and he even
Point Blank Googled the question why
hasn't the Long Island serial killer
been caught trying to figure out how
they were narrowing with cell phones
narrowing what incredible police work
from a thousand phones to 100 phones to
a handful of phones then that green
truck as Emily mentioned and then the
DNA evidence uh this is a sick guy he's
described as a demon that walked Among
Us by the Police Commissioner how Eerie
that is because when you talk to some of
his colleagues he's described as social
a big talker stand out very personable
apparently if he was in a room he would
seek out and make sure he talked to
every person in the in the room but
there was something very weird and odd
about him even so I feel for his wife I
feel for his kids their lives are
changed forever of course it's innocent
until proven guilty but what a
victorious day for those young women's
families who have been tireless and
pressing for answers this has been a big
case in the New York area for quite some
time that's true and it's been it's good
news for Fox because this is the same
neighborhood that Brian Kilmeade is from
and he's now no longer a person of
interest which is which is good we can
cross him off
I'm not joking I still have my
suspicions but I always watching Law
Enforcement when they get when they do
the press conference because they thank
everybody and it reminds me of like the
Oscars the best picture except these
people are real and these people are
heroes and they and and that you can see
how much it means to them and uh they're
not a bunch of pompous actors it's
actually the real thing uh this guy went
to Berner high school did you know that
that's also the high school uh that
Billy Baldwin went to so I think another
winner here is that Billy Baldwin can
say he's not the Biggest Loser from uh
burner high school it's actually he
can't I mean being a failed actor is
nothing like being a serial killer it is
weird though he you know what this
reminds me of you know how they always
say Law and Order the TV show Law and
Order uh their stories are ripped from
the headlines this is like a headline
rip from Law and Order because generally
you know the serial killer uh you know
you know in in Law and Order always
turns out to be an uh you know the white
middle class architect and everybody
went for the wrong person first and got
him but this is exactly has that TV
twist which oh you know he was known to
be quite personable and probably you
know was smarter than the average bear
but you know you know kept it low
profile and there he is can I see
another tall serial killer by the way we
talked about this exactly and can I say
the reason why they become serial is
because of that that lack of memory that
everyone has in us being associated with
them they are non-memorable they are not
someone that stands out in personality
or physically so that's partly why they
are able to fly under the radar because
they are sort of mundane that's why and
that's also why by the way when you
upload your DNA it's not 23andMe it's
not ancestry.com it's additional sites
and you have to toggle you have to
choose act delete a toggle to release
your DNA so that you can help cold cases
like this because otherwise the privacy
concerns have extinguished all of law
enforcement's efforts in that regard I
think too I mean it's like it this is
the problem with sex work in general is
that those are the kinds of of yes you
know victims you can choose because it's
essentially we've made them apart from
society maybe they're estranged from
their family and and so uh they're
they're specifically chosen for that
reason easy prey yeah and Emily's point
about technology and the growth in
technology and how that that those
improvements help us get here can't be
understated either so are you saying we
should give our DNA yes I believe firmly
yes I believe firmly you should
yes what we already did and on point one
percent black but I don't know if I
toggle don't tell the feds about it did
we toggle me I don't know I didn't do
your analysis we'll ask Johnny yes
exactly so in a week if I ever commit a
felony they got me coming up AI disrupts
another industry Hollywood actors going
on strike I went on Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now